NEPAL IS IN MOURNING FOLLOWING
SUNDAY'S PLANE CRASH NEAR THE
CITY OF POKHARA.
DOZENS OF PEOPLE ON BOARD A
YETI AIRLINES FLIGHT WERE
KILLED WHEN IT PLUNGED TO THE
GROUND.
JUST HOURS AGO, THESE WERE THE
SCENES AT A NEARBY HOSPITAL AS
FAMILY MEMBERS WAITED FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES BODIES TO BE
IDENTIFIED AND RELEASED.
SEARCH OPERATIONS AT THE CRASH
SITE HAVE ENDED FOR THE NIGHT.
THEY WILL RESUME ON TUESDAY AND
INVESTIGATORS HOPE TO LEARN
MORE SOON FROM THE PLANE'S TWO
FLIGHT RECORDERS WHICH HAVE NOW
BEEN RECOVERED.
CNN'S VEDIKA SUD SHOWS US
SOME OF THE FLIGHT'S FINAL
MOMENTS.
>> A VIDEO ON SOCIAL MEDIA
APPEARS TO SHOW THE PASSENGER
PLANE BANKING SUDDENLY, MOMENTS
BEFORE THE CRASH IN WESTERN
NEPAL.
ON SUNDAY MORNING, A YETI
AIRLINES OPERATED FLIGHT
EMBARKED ON A ROUGHLY 30-MINUTE
FLIGHT FROM THE CAPITAL OF
KATHMANDU TO POKHARA, THE
COUNTRY'S SECOND MOST POPULATED
CITY.
>> TRANSLATOR: WE HEARD A LOUD,
THUNDEROUS CRASH AND REACHED
OUR --
--
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENED.
WE SAW A LOT OF SMOKE AND
REALIZE THERE WAS A CRASH.
WE RUSHED TO THE SITE.
>> THE FLIGHT WAS LAST IN
CONTACT WITH THE POKHARA 18
MINUTES AFTER TAKEOFF BEFORE IT
CAME CRASHING DOWN IN THE
NEARBY GORGE.
IT IS THE DEADLIEST AIRCRAFT IN
MORE THAN THREE DECADES IN
NEPAL.
DOZENS OF BODIES HAVE BEEN
PULLED OUT OF THE GORGE USING
CRANES.
SOME HAVE YET TO BE IDENTIFIED
BY FAMILY MEMBERS.
ON MONDAY, RESCUE TEAMS
RETRIEVED THE BLACK BOXES.
THE FLIGHT DATA AND COCKPIT
VOICE RECORDER COULD HELP
UNDERSTAND THE MOMENTS LEADING
UP TO THE CRASH.
THE HIMALAYAN COUNTRY HAS A
RECORD OF AIR ACCIDENTS DUE TO
ITS MOUNTAINOUS TOPOGRAPHY AND
SUDDEN CHANGES TO THE WEATHER,
BUT IN THIS CASE, OFFICIALS SAY
IT WAS A CLEAR DAY.
THE NEPAL GOVERNMENT HAS SET UP
A PANEL TO PROBE THE AIR
ACCIDENT AND WILL HOPEFULLY
FIND ANSWERS TO WHAT LED TO THE
THIRD WORST AVIATION ACCIDENT
IN NEPAL'S HISTORY.
>> LET'S GET YOU TO THE
DEVELOPMENTS FROM NEW DELHI IN
NEIGHBORING INDIA.
HOW QUICKLY DO AUTHORITIES
BELIEVE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
REVEAL ANY FURTHER DETAILS ON
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY?
>> WELL, THAT THE, ACCORDING TO
THE NEPAL GOVERNMENT, IT'S
GOING TO TAKE ABOUT 45 DAYS FOR
ALL THE INVESTIGATION TEAM TO
ACTUALLY GO AHEAD AND SUBMIT
THEIR --
IT HAS BEEN CONSTITUTED.
IT IS A HUGE SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT THAT THE BLACK
BOXES, AS YOU MENTION, HAVE
BEEN RETRIEVED FROM THE CRASH
SITE.
THAT HOLDS THE KEY TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS, BECKY.
WE WILL GET TO KNOW ABOUT THE
LAST MOMENTS FROM THE BLACK
BOXES.
OFFICIALS HAVE TOLD CNN THAT
THEY ARE IN GOOD CONDITION.
THAT COULD ANSWER THE QUESTIONS,
NOT ONLY HELD BY THE
INVESTIGATORS, BUT ALSO THE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
THEY WILL BE LINING UP OUTSIDE
THE HOSPITALS WAITING TO
RECEIVE THE BODY OF THEIR LOVED
ONES.
AS FOR THE LATEST FROM THE
CRASH SITE, TODAY WAS DAY TWO
OF THE SEARCH OPERATIONS.
IT HAS ENDED WITH ONE BODY IN
ADDITION TO THE 68 RECOVERED ON
SUNDAY.
CRANES WERE USED TO PULL THESE
BODIES OUT FROM THE GORGE.
WE KNOW THAT ALL OF THESE
BODIES, A POSTMORTEM WILL BE
CONDUCTED.
THERE WERE 15 FOREIGN NATIONALS
ON BOARD THE FADED FLIGHT.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THE BODIES
WILL BE AIRLIFTED TO A HOSPITAL
AND KATHMANDU WHERE THE
POSTMORTEMS WILL BE CONDUCTED.
THEY WILL BE HANDED OVER TO
FAMILY MEMBERS, BUT ONLY 38
BODIES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
WE SPEAK.
THERE ARE A LOT MORE BODIES
WHICH NEED TO BE IDENTIFIED AT
THIS POINT.
HEARTBROKEN SCENES OUTSIDE THE
HOSPITAL --
FAMILIES ASKING WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED, TELL US MORE, BUT WE
HAVE TO WAIT FOR THOSE ANSWERS
FROM THE TEAM, THE PROBE TEAM
THAT IS INVESTIGATING THIS AIR
CRASH.
IT IS THE DEADLIEST IN MORE
THAN THREE DECADES.
>> VEDIKA SUD ON THE STORY,
THANK YOU.